where did all the money go
that's a great question right because
they didn't where all the staff where's
the BLM staff I know what it costs to
put on a massive live event I know what
it cost to put on these huge things they
didn't do any of that so you know what
we know of is just a very small sliver
of what really bad things they probably
did actually happen because you don't
know these things when C3 C4s they file
this way I don't even I'm not even
convinced BLM did anything untoward in a
certain sense you give them money they
can do what they want with they just
couldn't build there's no way you can
build a 100 million dollar organization
in basically a year or two years
but I mean they they the same people
were involved since 2013. right but they
they but they built the actual
organization within like a year after
getting all that money because they were
taking they're just taking in money
based off of the news and the climate
and from Corporate America like they
just didn't have the capability of
actually building this thing so it's not
a surprise that they've completely
failed